je suis né en banlieue parisienne très
loin de l'océan dans une cité bétonné
bitume et sans horizon
issu d'une famille monoparentale avec
une maman d'origine marocaine qui
faisait des ménages et personnes de
particulièrement sensibilisés à
l'environnement personne de marins dans
mon entourage
donc a priori il n'y a rien qui me
prédestinait à faire ce que je fais
aujourd'hui ce que je fais depuis plus
de 15 ans maintenant c'est à dire dédier
ma vie à la défense de l'océan
depuis 2005 la date où j'ai rencontré le
capitaine paul watson et où j'ai
découvert l'existence de l'eau et jesse
shepherd
j'ai participé ou j'ai mené des missions
de protection de la vie marine
en antarctique aux iles féroé aux
galapagos en méditerranée en afrique de
l'ouest et bien sûr en france
dans mes rêves les plus fous en tant
qu'enfants et même en tant
qu'adolescente jamais je n'aurais pensé
un jour pouvoir faire ça en partant
d'aussi loin quand je me retourne sur
mon parcours même s'il évolue toujours
je me rends compte qu'en fait il ya une
constante qui m'a toujours accompagné
c'est que j'ai toujours eu confiance en
moi en mes capacités et je me suis
nourri à la fois des encouragements mais
aussi des attaques et peut-être encore
plus des attaques
il y en a certaines des positives et
négatives pendant mon parcours scolaire
qui m'ont profondément marqué par
exemple mon professeur d'histoire
géographie en cinquième qui un jour me
rends un devoir sur table et il me dit
tu sais toi tu feras ce que tu veux dans
la vie tu pourras être ministre et si tu
veux rien ne sera hors de sa portée
alors j'ai pas du tout envie d'être
ministre mais aujourd'hui je fais
vraiment ce que j'ai le plus envie de
faire et les paroles de ce professeur
m'ont accompagné pendant longtemps elle
m'accompagne toujours je les ai fais
mienne et j'en ai fait ma vérité il ya
aussi d'autres paroles beaucoup plus
négative elle qui paradoxalement moins
aussi rendue plus forte
par exemple mon professeur de français
en seconde lors d'un rendez-vous
d'orientation
qui m'explique que je n'ai pas niveau
suffisant pour aller en filière générale
que je ne pourrai jamais réussir au bac
général est que les études ne sont pas
fait pour moi et pourtant j'aimais le
français mais j'avais de très mauvaises
notes avec lui donc j'ai décidé au
contrôle suivant de travailler pour une
fois et j'ai eu 15 sur 20 il a été très
surpris et il m'a dit tu vois quand tu
veux tu peux et je lui ai répondu mais
je le savais maintenant vous le savez
aussi si j'ai des mauvaises notes avec
vous c'est pas parce que j'ai pas niveau
c'est parce que vos cours m'ennuie et
j'ai arrêté de travailler après ça alors
je dis pas que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
mais en tout cas moi j'avais fait ma
démonstration
je lui avais dit ce que j'avais le vide
hier une autre professeur marquer ma
prof d'anglais en terminale l'anglais
c'est une matière que je travaillais
pour le coup j'avais des bonnes notes
j'étais déjà très motivé à l'idée de
voyager et donc j'avais compris que
l'anglais était important donc je
faisais des efforts et ça paye est par
contre cette professeur a eu des mots
qui m'ont marqué aussi il y avait une
fille dans la classe qui s'appelait
audrey pineau et elle m'a dit un jour
dans toute la classe
ne vous leurrez pas mademoiselle entre
essemlali et pino un employeur choisira
toujours pinault donc ce sont des
paroles qui marque qui nourrissent aussi
un sentiment d'injustice que j'utilise
moi personnellement comme un carburant
aujourd'hui je me retourne là dessus et
ce que je vois c'est que j'ai fait des
études j'ai fait un master en sciences
de l'environnement à l'université pierre
et marie curie et j'ai réussi à
convaincre un employeur de me faire
confiance pour mes capacités de ne pas
s'arrêter à mon nom de famille j'ai même
c'est plus que ça parce que finalement
en créant l'antenne française de sea
shepherd
même si ça n'était absolument pas mon
objectif à la base j'ai créé mon emploi
on est parti d'un carton petit shirt
pour lancer cette antenne est
aujourd'hui c'est une des antennes
nationales les plus importantes de sea
shepherd au niveau monde
elle j'ai fait aucun calcul pour ça je
pense que si j'avais été dans la
stratégie j'aurais jamais pris le chemin
que j'ai pris ce qui m'amène à une autre
chose qui est importante à mon sens le
fait de sortir des sentiers battus
quand j'étais étudiante et que j'allais
sur les salons étudiants les slogans
affichés partout c'était quelles sont
les filières qui recrutent
ça m'a toujours choqué est ce qu'on doit
finalement prendre son orientation
professionnelle en fonction des filières
qui recrutent ou est-ce qu'on doit
essayer de trouver sa voie
finalement c'est tellement important le
temps qu'on passe au travail et c'est
aussi l'impact qu'on a sur cette planète
être en conviction avec ce qu'on fait
tous les jours
est ce que finalement c'est pas ça le
luxe ultime c'est ce que j'ai réussi à
obtenir parce que d'une part je me suis
fait confiance et j'ai décidé que
personne ne connaissait ma valeur mieux
que moi et qui ne tenait qu'à moi de me
trouver et de prouver aux autres et
aussi parce que j'ai réussi à résister
aux sirènes d'une société qui formate
l'esprit des jeunes et qui leur fait
croire qu'il n'y a qu'une voie possible
et qui n'est pas raisonnable de
s'écouter est-ce qu'il n'est pas plutôt
complètement fou de se caler dans un
moule qui ne nous correspond pas
finalement quand j'ai repris les études
pour passer ce fameux masters donc
j'avais 24 ans j'ai dû faire une remise
à niveau scientifique parce que j'avais
pas un bac scientifique
aucune femme ne voulait de moi j'ai
plutôt un bagage littéraire
donc j'ai repris ses études à 24 ans et
je suis parti donc pour 6 en un an de
mise à niveau 5 ans pour le masters et
je me souviens que dans mon entourage on
disait que j'avais beaucoup de courage
et moi j'avais pas le sentiment d'avoir
du courage
en fait j'avais surtout le sentiment de
ne pas avoir de choix parce que même
plus que le courage finalement ce qui me
motivait ce qui me poussait c'était la
peur parce qu'il ya une chose qui m'a
toujours fait plus peur que la mort
c'est la peur de passer à côté de la vie
pour moi c'était fondamental et ça ne me
laissait pas d'autre choix que celui
d'avancer sur cette voie là parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais persuadé qu'avoir un
master en sciences de l'environnement
était indispensable pour faire ce que je
veux faire aujourd'hui
avec le recul je sais que j'aurais pu
choisir d'autres voies mais je ne
regrette pas du tout parce que passé ce
masters ça m'a permis d'avoir un bagage
scientifique de connaître le milieu
universitaire et de le désacraliser
aussi d'une certaine façon est donc ça
contribue à me rendre plus forte aussi
en tant qu'activiste finalement cette
peur de passer à côté de la vie ça a
toujours été mon curseur premier et
c'est ce qui m'a mis sur la route du
capitaine paul watson qui a été une
rencontre déterminante dans ma vie parce
qu'il m'a montré par l'exemple que des
choses que je pensais être impossible
était en fait possible il n'a montré
qu'en fait il n'était pas fou ni
déraisonnable de consacrer s'agit à
défendre la vie à défendre l'océan
il m'a montré par l'exemple que quelque
chose auquel on peut croire de façon
philosophique peut s'appliquer aussi
dans les actes et c'est en ça que quand
j'ai connu six shepherd
j'ai complètement trouvé chaussure à mon
pied parce que le modus operandi très
combative de l'organisation correspond à
mon tempérament et en même temps la
défense de l'océan pour moi c'est aussi
une lutte contre une injustice ultime
parce que l'océan et massacré la vie
marine et massacrés dans des proportions
qui sont sans commune mesure par rapport
à ce qu'on peut faire sur terre et dans
une inconscience général peut être une
cause perdue en fait et finalement la
cause qui me donne le plus envie de me
battre pour elle il ya plusieurs choses
aussi autour de la défense de l'océan
l'océan est le premier organe de
régulation du climat avant les forêts
c'est aussi le premier fournisseur
d'oxygène c'est la vie marine qui nous
permet de respirer plus d'une
inspiration sur deux quand je vous parle
je la dois à la vie marine
mais l'océan c'est pas que ça
l'océan c'est aussi l'ultime par
sauvages du monde l'incarnation
fondamental de la liberté
donc il permet à nos cordes survivre en
eau par
temps de respirer et il permet aussi à
nos âmes de survivre en nous permettant
de rêver cette liberté qu'un quart de
l'océan elle m'a tellement manqué dans
mon enfance et mon adolescence dans
cette banlieue parisienne sans horizon
que gelée profondément recherché j'ai
profondément envie de la défendre et
cette liberté cette question de la
liberté de l'activisme mais aussi amené
à m'interroger sur une question
importante notamment quand on est une
femme
la question de la maternité et donc je
vais finir avec quelques mots sujet de
ma fille mila j'ai longtemps hésité à
être maman
d'abord parce que ça me faisait plus
peur quand vie pendant très longtemps et
aussi parce que très clairement nous
sommes plus de sept milliards d'êtres
humains et je pense que la planète a pas
besoin de ma progéniture est donc cette
question là cette question
environnementale
ma m'a poussé à y réfléchir finalement
par amour et par égoïsme
j'ai franchi le pas et j'ai eu une
petite fille il ya quatre ans et j'ai
été très étonné de voir qu en fait là où
je pensais que ça me couperait les ailes
ça a décuplé leur envergure
d'abord parce que à travers les yeux de
ma fille je redécouvre le monde avec
cette capacité d'émerveillement qu'ont
les enfants que les adultes eux perdent
au fur et à mesure ce côté un peu blasé
qui vient endormir nos sens et à travers
elle j'ai le sentiment que la vie me
donner une seconde chance me rappeler un
peu que la beauté est dans les choses
simples et dans le moment présent
un peu comme si la nature me donner un
shot d'enfance dans mes veines d'adultes
un peu désabusé
j'ai eu le sentiment vraiment que moi
qui avait tout donné à la nature elle me
faisait le plus beau des cadeaux mon
retour
ça aussi décupler mon activisme dans le
sens où ce pourquoi je me battais avant
elle devenait du coup maintenant le
monde dans lequel elle allait grandir et
ce monde qu'on est en train de décider
aujourd'hui risquent d'être l'enfer pour
nos enfants
comme toute personne mon enfant est ce
que j'ai de plus cher au monde et je
suis prête à tout donner et à tout
risquer pour lui éviter l'enfer donc à
travers cette maternité
j'ai nourri mon activisme et pour moi
aujourd'hui l' équilibre il est plutôt
de trouver le temps suffisant pour être
à la fois une maman activistes et une
maman présente pour que ma fille n'est
jamais le sentiment qu'elle n'est pas ma
priorité parce qu'elle l'est et elle ne
fait que booster ma motivation il l'un
se nourrit de l'autre est une chose qui
est fondamental je pense
on dit souvent qu'il faut qu'on laisse
une belle planète à nos enfants
pour moi il est essentiel qu'on laisse
de bons enfants à notre planète et c'est
ce que je m'efforce de faire avec mila
l'élever dans le respect du vivant dont
elle fait partie et elle fera ensuite
ses propres choix
comme j'ai pu faire les biens